[音楽]
見てくださいこの写真みんな
めっちゃいい笑顔ですよねすごく
嬉しそうです
デリーの大学で
折り紙ワークショップをした時の写真です
学生さんとか数学の教授とかあと近所の
小学生もたくさん来てくれました
私自身はヒンズ語は全くできませんで英語
もそれほどうまく話せるわけではありませ
ん
でも
折り紙のワークショップでは言葉の壁と
いうのはそれほど大きな問題にはならない
んです
折り紙の折り方は手の運動を模倣すること
で人から人に
伝えることができます
コミュニケーションツールとして
折り紙を捉える時にこの性質はとても重要
なポイントになります
しかしさらにもう一つ
コミュニケーションする際にとっても
パワフルなポイントがあるんです
折り紙には数学が含まれているという事実
ですいやいやいや
折り紙はまあまだいいけど数学はちょっと
苦手なんですよという声が聞こえてきそう
ですね
でも安心してください
折り紙は
紙を折っているだけで勝手に数学やっ
ちゃってるんです
例えば正方形の紙を半分に折って三角形を
作ったとします
そうすると一番長い辺の長さは
√2です
無理数です
人よ人より人身頃という語呂合わせで
覚えた方も多くいらっしゃるんじゃない
でしょうか
でも無限に続いていて割り切れない数字
なんてちょっとどう扱っていいかなんと
なくつかみどころがないですよね
でもこうやって紙を折って作るともう実際
に存在している長さなんだってことが一発
でわかるんですもう無理数あるやん無理
ちゃうやんって感じですよね
もう一つ別の例を見てみましょう
正方形が一つあってその正方形の面積を
半分にした正方形を作らないといけないと
いう事態になったとしますそんな事態に
なることあるのっていう話ではあるんです
けどそれはちょっと一旦置いといてこれが
折り紙だと
めちゃめちゃ簡単にできるんです
一辺の長さがルート1/2だからとかいう
計算も作図のための道具も何にも必要あり
ません
ただ単に4つの角を中心に合わせて
折るだけなんです
でこの折り方は
折り紙の世界では
座布団折っていう風に呼ばれています
座布団には
折り紙をやっているともう
至る所に出てきます
頻出単語です
さっき私言いましたよね
正方形の面積半分数になった正方形作るの
になんかそんな事態あるのって
めっちゃあるんです
もうアホほどあるんですなので
折り紙の世界では
元の正方形の半分の面積の正方形を作ると
いうことにものすごく大きな
ニーズがあるんですここ覚えておいて
くださいね
でこんな風に
折り紙というのは数学と一心同体切っても
切れない素敵な相棒です
数学は世界中で使われているとっても
グローバルな共通言語です
なので
折り紙は
世界中で
理解できるんですね
年齢も
地域もそれから言葉の壁も超えてみんなが
理解できるようになっているだからみんな
で一緒に楽しむことができるんです
でも時々聞こえてくる声があります
数学ばっかりを前面に押し出すとなんか
人間味のない冷たい作品になってしまい
ませんかとか
数学っていうのは誰が解いても同じ回に
なるから
作家の個性が発揮できないんじゃないです
かと言った不安の声です
でも心配ご無用まずはこちらをご覧
ください
方程式です
中学で習います
2x引く4=0これを1番目の式にします
両辺に4を足すと
2x=4これを2番目の式にします
次に両辺を2で割ります
X=2これが3番目の式です
次に両辺に3をかけます
3x=6これが4番目の式です
ではここで質問です
1番から4番のうち
解はどれでしょうか
1番が回だと思う人手を挙げてください
はいでは2番が回だと思う人はいでは3番
が買いだと思う人あーたくさん
いらっしゃいますねはいありがとうござい
ますでは4番が回だと思う人はい
ありがとうございます実はこれ
全部正解なんです
学校では3番の形が貝だと習います
でもよく考えるとちょっと不思議なんです
よね
1番から4番というのは
式変形をしているだけなので
数学的には全部同値です対等なんです
なのになぜ3番の形の式だけが回として
特別扱いされているんでしょうか
短くて分かりやすいから
シンプルでエレガントだから
これって人間のエゴですよね
重要なのは誰にとっての会なのかという
視点です
会の形は
解を求める人の都合によって選ばれます
わかりやすい形使いやすい形
綺麗な形かっこいい形
その中には
解を求める人の
センスや哲学が
必ず入り込んでいて切り離すことができ
ません
方程式の解ですらそうなんですから
数学をバリバリ使って作った作品にも
必ずその作者の
センスがしっかり入り込んでいるんです
なので私はもう全然遠慮せずに数学
ジャンジャン使いますもう本当に好きな
だけいくらでも使いたい放題なん
ですそうやって作った作品が例えばこちら
会場に実物も持ってきました
これトゲトゲした形のものや
丸い形のもの
から
結晶のような
角張った形のものもあります
こういう新しい作品の形を作るとき私は
方程式の解を選ぶときのような感覚を感じ
ます
例えばこれは
三角形の何かなんですがこれに1人加える
と
兜になります
さらに
折り線を加えると
別の形を作ることもできます
これらはみんなもともと正方形の1枚の紙
で
折りたたまれ方が違うだけです
では会はどれでしょう
この中に
貝はあるでしょうか
実際の
創作の現場では事態はもう少し
複雑です
例えばこれは
昔作った作品の例です
金色の部分がラッパ状になっていてその
根元の角度を少しずつ変えて作ると
出来上がりの形が変わります
折り線を足したり引いたり
時には何ヶ月も何年も一つの作品について
試行錯誤を繰り返します
バリエーションの一つ一つは実際に存在し
ているわけですからそれぞれを作品だと
言って主張することも可能でしょう
ですが
この大量の
選択肢の中からこれだという一つ
究極の一つを選ぶ瞬間
自分の魂にジャストフィットする会を選ぶ
その瞬間が
創作活動の中で一番強く輝く
瞬間なんです
折り紙は
通学が含まれています
そのために
数学の持つ共通言語としての特徴を
折り紙も持っています
そのために
単なる
模倣を超えて作品の
背後にある意味や法則性といったものも
世界中の誰もが
理解できる構造になっているんです
理解できるということは
応用が利くということです
自分の個性を自分の手で自分の作品に
載せていくことができるようになるんです
ワークショップで習った作品の角を
ちょっとだけ
反対側に折り返してみる
そんな小さなアクションが無限の
バリエーションとその先にある自己表現と
しての
創作活動へとつながっていくんです
ありがとうございました
[拍手]